all right so bailey what when it comes
to billy eilish
celebs have questions and she's shocked
that some of her faves want answers
i love it in a new video with british
vogue billy is surprised by over 22 of
her famous fans
asking the singer a lot of very
interesting personal questions
starting off with missy elliott who
wanted to know more about billy's music
i was wondering is there any songs that
you recorded that you
love but you didn't get a chance to
shoot a video for and if
so what songs are they oh my god
elliott oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god
i love you is one of my favorite songs
of my own
and i didn't get to make a video for it
same with hilo milo it's just like the
time got away from me you know
but of course music wasn't necessarily
on every celeb's mind
including orlando bloom who needed some
advice on being plant-based
as somebody who's like 90 flame-based at
this point
i wonder what your reasoning for being
vegan was
i just can't go on in my life
knowing what's going on in the animal
world and like
not doing anything about it then there
was justin bieber who claims he had a
really serious question for billy
would you rather fresh socks or fresh
sheets but i can't have both justin it
really depends the situation i really
don't
want to sleep in dirty sheets and i
really don't want to put on dirty socks
you know
i feel like fresh sheets but also i
i can't wear dirty socks billy has been
very open about being a huge justin
bieber stan since she was 12.
even admitting that she used to sob over
him et spoke with billy in 2019 about
her love for the pop star
and what it was like to finally
communicate with him oh the first thing
he sent was a screenshot
of a dm i sent him in 2014.
stop so he remembered from twenty he
didn't remember it but you know
when you follow somebody yeah you can
see everything they've dm'd you in the
past
right so when he started following you
he got the notification
yeah oh what should that do for your
heart
that's amazing it like felt good and it
felt bad at the same time yeah but it
was amazing he's he's so sweet and like
i feel i just honestly i feel for him
man
another fun slub question came from
sportyspice
mel c who at first reminisced on the
last time she saw billy
it has been a while in fact it was the
brits
february 2020 and what an incredible
night i was so excited to present
your award to you she later asked billy
one of the hardest questions
what has been the biggest moment in her
life since then
i think the grammys was one of those i
think
the oscars was one of those um
and honestly every every moment i have
is incredible and i
miss it so much last june mel c opened
up to e.t
about meeting billy and why is she so
proud of her star power
she completely understands she's so wise
beyond her years
she knows she has a very powerful
platform
you know to be speaking from and she's
using it in the best way and it's brave
as well you know because everybody has
an opinion and everybody is ready to
criticize when you're in those positions
and you know i feel extremely proud of
her
and you know i feel for all young
artists now because
the spice girls didn't have to deal with
social media and
very very different time and you know we
felt pressure we felt like we had a
responsibility to our younger fans
um but now you know you are literally
under the spotlight
um but she handles it beautifully so
yeah
more power